>>Rick Needham: Thanks everyone for coming
in today.
It's a gorgeous day outside, so I know it's
a tough draw to pull you indoors.
Hopefully everyone's had a chance to go look
around outside about all the Earth Day activities
that are going on out there.
You've got vendor booths, partner booths,
some informational booths.
We even have out own internal teams that have
their own little booths.
A ride-and-drive, and stuff like that.
But I'd love to introduce you to Dan Yates.
I'm Rick Needham, I'm part of our Energy and
Sustainability team here at Google.
One of the many teams that focuses on sustainability.
And I have the pleasure of introducing you
to Dan, who's a really interesting guy.
He's obviously founded and is currently CEO
of Opower, which is a company that's developing
home management, energy management software
that actually is connected with over somewhere
in the order of 10 to 15 million people, homes
already.
That's quite an extensive reach that they
have in North America, the UK.
They've saved enough power already to power
the Empire State Building for something like
10 years.
Not a small amount of savings already.
Pretty amazing.
Before Opower, Dan actually had founded an
educational software company called Edusoft,
ended up selling that, and then embarking
on this trip which I think he'll talk a little
bit about, which sounds really cool to me.
One day I'd love to do it, too.
It went from the Arctic Circle up in Alaska
all the way down to the southern tip of South
America.
At first, I thought it was biking, and he
said, "No, no, no, it's actually driving.
We drove a car."
But that's still quite an amazing trip.
And on that trip, that's when he realized
he wanted to dedicate his professional career
to helping maintain the wild places in the
world, and dedicate himself to sustainability.
He's also been cited many times, several awards
too.
He's won the Ernst and Young Entrepreneur
of the Year award.
In the greater Washington area has been a
Tech Titan, which sounds like a really cool
label three years in a row.
Awesome.
[laughter] And so, something else I found
out at lunch is that Dan's also a consummate
hula-hooper.
Unfortunately, I wasn't able to procure a
hula-hoop in time for the talk.
>>Dan Hayes: Such a shame.
>>Rick: He didn't tell me in time.
Now it's too late.
But if we run out of good questions, which
I hope we don't, you can always ask about
how he became a good hula-hooper.
But please join me in welcoming Dan.
>>Dan Hayes: That was a little Stephen Colbert
moment, right?
>>Rick: Was it?
Yeah, okay.
Thank you, Dan.
Okay, thanks, Dan, whoo!
Please join me in welcoming Dan Yates to Google.
[applause]
>>Dan Yates: Thanks a lot.
It's good to be here.
I actually just realized: is there any clicker
capability?
'Cause otherwise I will be married to the--.
No clicker.
Okay.
I will stand here behind the podium for most
of this.
Unless this is going-- no, it will not.
Okay.
Well, good.
I'm happy to be here.
I'm excited to be here on Earth Day and honored
to be invited to talk.
Better than Halloween, I guess.
I was thinking about what I should talk about.
Some of you probably know a little bit about
Opower already.
I'll give you a quick overview and then over
the course of this presentation tell a little
bit more about the company.
I was thinking about Earth Day as a day where
we're all supposed to be trying to take a
day to think about how we can do more to help
the environment.
As I was thinking about that, and I've been
thinking about recently that the evolution
and the progression of clean tech companies
over the last 5 years since I got into this
business.
It hit me that there was a theme that I wanted
to talk about.
What I want to do is I want to tell a story
of incremental improvement.
I want to talk not about revolutionary improvement,
but evolutionary improvement.
When I started Opower, there were all these
big, fast-growing clean tech companies: in
solar, in wind, in biofuels.
Many of these companies haven't panned out.
I went through this period of about 3 or 4
years where I was really disappointed to see
there weren't a lot of other companies even
chasing after Opower or doing other-- successfully
building clean tech companies and having an
impact.
And that started to change in the last few
years.
There's been a second surge of companies.
If you tune into this, you'll hear a lot of
talk about how these new clean tech companies,
many of them are focused on efficiency, like
Opower.
But there's a lot of talk also how they're
very capital efficient.
They don't need $500 million to get going.
That is a very important precursor, I think,
to successfully building a company.
If you need a half million dollars to get
it going, you're going to have a very few
number of businesses that are going to get
off the ground.
But I think that the story, the thing that
has been last talked about, which I actually
think is one of the most important ones, is
this difference of not trying to boil the
ocean, but looking for incremental improvements
that, when you add them up, actually end up
being really massive.
When I think about Opower, that's the story
of our success.
Let me start at the beginning and tell you
how this came to be, hopefully, in the process,
carry you through this.
Hey Eric, good to see you there.
[laughs] I see a lot of faces in the audience
that I recognize.
But hopefully carry you through and see this
story of incrementalism.
It all started, as described, with a trip
through the Americas starting at the very
top and ending at the very bottom.
This photo here is me and my wife as we were
in Bolivia.
One of the highest points of the trip.
It's something like 16,000 feet.
So we took this trip.
We drove for about a year, heading south.
It was easy to get directions.
We went on the trip just to have fun.
I'd sold my last company, an educational software
company.
And I grew up camping and liked backpacking
but wasn't environmentally minded in terms
of what I wanted to do with the rest of my
life.
I still say I don't know the difference between
the horned owl and the spotted owl and I probably
won't ever.
But we went on this trip to have a great time,
and we did.
We saw the things that we thought we were
going to see.
We saw beautiful animals, we saw this vicuña
in the Bolivian Altiplano, a rare cousin of
a llama.
We saw these amazing forest canopies.
I love this photo because it's just so amazing,
the efficiency with which these trees grow
together, yet just stop growing right where
the other one takes over and capture all the
sunlight.
We had a great time.
We also did a lot of fun tourist stuff.
But in the process, we saw a lot of the reality
of what it's like out there in the rest of
the world.
I left on this trip with this naive picture
that the US was the most inhabited, most developed
country.
In reality, when you go through the rest of
the Americas, it's not true.
We actually have some pretty rich wildlands
that are well protected.
There are other countries that are totally
devastated.
They're not devastated because these guys--
these are not bad guys, these are just poor
people who are trying to incrementally eke
out a living.
Unfortunately, their incremental steps are
working against the environment.
So I came back feeling very viscerally how
at risk and fragile the environment is.
I'm not going to spend any more time talking
about this point, because I'm quite confident
that everyone here in this room knows how
at risk and fragile the environment is.
But this is a key part of my story.
This is when, for me, it became really visceral
because I couldn't-- After this trip, I no
longer had to envision it or imagine it, I
could remember it.
I could remember all the spots where I saw
the fragility and I saw how at risk the environment
was.
When I came back, I thought about what I should
do.
Basically asked myself the simple question,
"What do we suck at here?"
And the answer was pretty clear.
At the end of the day, where we're by far
doing the worst is that we use a lot of dirty
energy.
I wanted to figure out what I could do to
have an impact.
This is 2006.
There was actually a lot of energy, pun intended,
clearly.
I was living in San Francisco, surrounded
by entrepreneurs talking about clean tech.
We were getting -- There was a lot of progress
on wind development.
There was a lot of progress on new solar:
with the utility scale solar here but also
residential solar is taking off.
The very first inklings of electric vehicles.
These things all seemed so full of potential,
and they are full of potential.
I was living in San Francisco, working out
of this tiny home office, and I downloaded
this graph, which was from the DOE, or the
Energy Information Agency.
This is a wonky little picture that I actually
just found an updated version of this morning.
Well, almost updated.
2010 anyhow.
This is how we use energy in the US.
On the left, you've got all the sources of
the generation.
And then on the right, you have all the consumption.
It hit me, 'cause I had this thing literally
just taped on the wall next to my computer,
that every single person I was talking to
that was innovating in clean tech-- I'd gone
to the big solar conference in San Jose.
It was the second annual conference, and there
were thousands of people there, and Governor
Schwarzenegger came and talked.
There was just so much enthusiasm for this.
Absolutely every innovation and idea that
was being discussed was over here.
There was no one talking about the right side.
I really actually think it was thanks to this
diagram that I could just see so plainly there
was this gap missing, this hole.
I just started to ask simply, "What about
just using less energy?
What can we do there?
Why aren't people focusing on this problem?"
I'm somewhat of a contrarian, so it gave me
a lot of pleasure to think that nobody was
thinking about this problem.
I didn't have an idea yet, but I knew that
there was some open space to hunt around.
So Mackenzie has done a very nice job.
This is actually-- Their studies came out
after we started Opower, but quantifying just
how much energy is being wasted.
It is astonishing.
Just looking at residential energy use in
the US, at wasted energy between now and 2020,
we're going to waste $400 billion of energy,
which is almost 5 trillion pounds of CO2 and
3.4 million gigawatt hours of energy.
This is not energy wasted because you bought
an extra TV, which you could argue is energy
wasted.
But this is energy wasted by your TV that
you bought when you're not using it.
Energy wasted by your air conditioner that
you're running when you're not home and is
making no one more comfortable.
It's just a tremendous amount of waste that's
sitting there.
So I couldn't help-- So it felt big and unattended,
but then the important question is: why?
Why are people wasting all this energy?
It seems like a no-brainer.
This is energy that, if saved, will actually
save money.
You don't even have to care about the environment
to save this energy.
This isn't like solar where it's more expensive
than coal.
This is just not wasting money and energy.
No one's winning.
Here are some of the reasons why.
6 minutes, 6 minutes is the average amount
of time that an American spends thinking about
energy use in a year.
[sighs] We all-- Most of us here, probably
unwilling to admit it, but most of us here
probably think about Justin Bieber more than
we think about our energy use on an annual
basis.
It's just completely not paid attention to.
The reason why is-- There's a couple reasons.
First one is it's boring.
It's just not a fun thing to think about.
The second thing, which is the more fundamental
problem, is that it's inexpensive.
The average American home spends only 1.7%
of their annual income on electricity.
If you save 25% on your energy bill, that's
like 0.45% impact on your overall expenditures
for the year.
It's just not a big deal.
So it's boring, it's inexpensive, and the
last thing is, is there's just no feedback
mechanism.
This is a programmable thermostat, one of
many crummy ones out there.
There are a great companies, including Opower,
that are now working to make these thermostats
much, much more user friendly.
But today, the average programmable thermostat
is not programmed.
In fact, 80% of them are not programmed.
And almost nobody remembers to turn off the
air conditioner when they leave the house.
Why is that?
They're hard to program, but they're not that
hard to program, and you can save a lot of
money doing it.
It's 'cause there's no feedback.
You don't feel bad when you leave the house
and the thermostat isn't programmed.
What I've liked to say for a long time is
if CO2 were purple and it smelled like rotten
eggs, we wouldn't have an energy problem.
You would turn off your thermostat because
your house would stink if you didn't, your
neighbors would see it and get angry, you'd
have the hassle of the purple smoke.
But there is no feedback.
There's no emotional connection to this.
It isn't visceral.
It's not that expensive.
And so we all just plow along and we waste
our $400 billion worth of electricity.
Okay.
So these are all problems, right?
So how do we fix this?
How do we correct these misconceptions?
I was looking at this, thinking about these
different ideas, and I was very fortunate
to run across this study by Robert Cialdini,
who is a world-renown behavioral psychologist.
He's written a book called Influence that's
prescribed reading at the GSB and at Harvard
Business School, published in a dozen languages
internationally.
He had just done this study.
What he was trying to do was he was trying
to figure out how to get people to take an
environmental action, and figure out what
would motivate people to save energy.
So here's the study he did.
He was in San Marcos, CA, a suburb of San
Diego, and he was trying to get people to
turn off their air conditioner and turn on
their fan in the evening.
He had a bunch of grad students working for
him.
They went around and printed up all these
door hangers.
They went door to door.
They hung these things on the doors.
And they had different treatments.
They had a control where they actually had
two different varieties of control.
There was very statistically significant,
well-structured academic study.
They would read the meters in each of the
homes after they had hung up these door hangers
to see if they were having an impact.
The first treatment was monetary: "You know,
you could save 50 bucks every month if you
turn off your AC and switch to a fan."
Second one was environmental: "Help save the
environment.
Keep the sky clean.
Take xyz pounds of CO2 out of the air.
Just turn off your AC and switch to a fan
in the evening."
Third message was a societal, citizenship.
"Save money for future-- Help conserve resources
for future generations.
Turn off your AC and switch to a fan in the
evening."
They did this week after week all summer long.
These groups, zero impact.
It was as if they had not been there.
And this is about as expensive a marketing
campaign as you can do.
No company can afford to go door to door,
even with grad students, hanging door hangers
every week.
If we can't get people to do some simple no-cost
behavioral change with this kind of marketing,
nothing's going to work.
But wait!
There was one more treatment.
Make room for it.
There was a simple last door hanger that said,
"In a recent survey of your neighbors, 75%
of them turn off their AC and switch to a
fan in the evening.
Join your neighbors.
Turn off your AC, switch to a fan in the evening."
This group saved 6%.
This sustained throughout the duration of
the study, all through the summer.
What does this mean?
It means that people benchmark to the norm.
We know this in a lot of other circumstances.
But this is a really powerful tool.
It's actually a very rational thing for us
to do.
The instinct that we all have when we hear
this is "keeping up with the Joneses."
We like to keep up with the Joneses and we've
all been taught by our moms and dads not to
keep up with the Joneses because it's not
how you're supposed to live your life.
But the reality is that if you're operating
in a complex environment like energy usage,
you don't know much about it.
You don't want to be an expert: most people
don't.
Benchmarking to what the wisdom of the crowd
says is actually a really good shortcut for
figuring out whether or not you're in line.
Whether you're doing what you ought to be
doing or living your life the way that is
most reasonable.
We see norms throughout our lives.
We have these buffoonish guys who are all
very happy with themselves because they all
look like each other and they're not ashamed
of it.
But you put one of them in this room, they
might feel a little awkward.
And then you have, on the nicer side of the
spectrum, women in beautiful saris.
No one here is wearing a sari today, but this
is absolutely a norm that is-- and they're
all almost wearing the same color sari, actually.
That is totally established in other parts
of the world, and totally normal and beautiful.
If we had norms like this about energy use,
we'd probably all start wearing the same energy
clothes and start drafting off of each other.
But there is no signals.
Most people don't know if they're efficient
or not.
To me, the data that-- the graph that has
most illustrated this for me is this graph,
which I have not labeled, so you have to wait
with bated breath for me to explain what it
is.
We have a ton of data.
We have almost half of the US energy data
under management in our colocation facilities,
Edipower, because we work with most of the
major utilities in the US.
When we work with them, the first thing they
do is they send us all their consumer energy
data.
We've been able to do some really interesting
analytics.
What we looked at, and this is actually something
we did from the very beginning, is we looked
at: how dispersed is the energy consumption
of a set of similar homes in the same neighborhood?
Taking for each home the hundred closest homes
of similar square footage of closest proximity--
basically an algorithm that weights your distance
in real distance with your distance in terms
of house size, and tries to find the minimally
distant set of homes.
How different is consumption across those
homes?
This is the graph that we get no matter where
we do it.
What it basically comes out is that in any
given home, in any given neighborhood, more
than 30%-- more than 50% of the homes are
further than 30% from the mean.
You get this big dispersion of energy use.
To me, the signal that-- What this signifies
is a couple things.
First, everything I just said: energy use
is-- there is no feedback, and people are
drifting off on their own trajectories of
consumption, some using more, some using less.
The second thing is that energy use is elastic,
because if there's this much variability within
similar homes in similar areas, there must
be an opportunity to reduce their usage.
This is what gave me a lot of the confidence
early on when we started the company that
there would be an opportunity to change the
norms and to move behaviors.
The opportunity was clear.
Thanks to the study by Robert Cialdini and
some research that we did on how energy efficiency
markets work.
There's about a $10 billion a year energy
efficiency market internationally.
We ran some math and realized that if we could
make-- if we could change behavior by a few
percent, we could actually have a real business.
So where do we start?
Here.
We started with the utility bill.
This is your typical craptastic utility bill.
[laughter] Barely tells you how much you owe.
It gives you-- this is actually a real bill.
I think we cut off the name of the utility
to save their reputation, but you've got the
price of natural gas to 8 decimal points,
just for good measure.
And yet, no useful information to really help
you figure anything else out about your usage
other than how much you owe.
So this felt like a big opportunity to improve,
and we applied all the lessons from that study
and our own best practices from direct marketing
and software analytics to deliver this first
product.
This was Opower's home energy report.
We did our first program with SMUD, just up
in Sacramento nearby.
We started sending home these mailers that
showed people how their energy use compared
to their neighbors, to their approximately
hundred occupied homes that are similar in
size.
We gave-- Alex Eagle here actually wrote a
lot of the energy calculator code that made
this first report possible.
We sent these out.
We set it up as a clinical trial with a test
and control groups so that we were able to
exactly measure the impact.
And we started to get these great results.
Here are many results now from many of our
utility programs.
Each line represents the difference between
the average consumption of the control group
minus the test group.
We've consistently been getting this 1.5-3.5%
reduction.
It's gone on now for over 4 years.
Every year, we tend to see a slight increment
in savings of these groups as they progress
and customers accumulate some energy saving
measures that are long lasting like somebody
replaces a refrigerator, etcetera.
Important to our business model, which is
not as important to the environment but is
important to our longevity: when you turn
off this program, the savings diminish.
Once you use us, you're hooked.
But the thing that I also want to flag-- and
these are just some of the groups that have
certified are results, the third parties that
have evaluated it.
But the thing that I want to highlight is:
1.5-3.5% doesn't seem like that much, right?
It isn't.
For a consumer, if I were selling it to you,
you wouldn't be disinterested, you wouldn't
buy it.
Luckily, our business is we sell to utilities,
they buy blocks of hundreds of thousands or
millions of homes and we deliver it and it's
free to the consumer.
But for an average consumer, this isn't a
big impact.
I'll get back to that in a few slides, 'cause
I want to show you how much this has added
up to.
We started with this normative comparison,
but behavioral science was just the beginning.
We immediately started to look to analytics
and what we could do with personalized recommendations.
I just want to highlight-- I'll touch on just
a couple of the neat things that we do, and
then I'll bring this speech to a close and
we can talk further.
This is one of the features that I really,
really like.
What we do is-- We are now-- We don't have
Google-sized data, but we have some pretty
big data.
We're running it all on a Hadoop grid.
We've custom developed a batch processing
system that sits on top of it because we need
perfect reliability and restartability of
our batch jobs because we're not just running
large scale approximate analytics.
We have to get results for every single customer
and get it right every single time.
We've got this system that's pretty slick.
A data platform that we've built.
What we do on it is we're able to run this
multivariate regression analysis where we
can separate out-- Using your smart meter
data and the local weather data stream, the
hourly data stream, using both temperature
and humidity, we're able to separate out the
parts of your usage, the biggest piece of
your usage: your heating, your cooling, your
baseload, which is the stuff that's on all
the time, and then everything else.
With that, we're able to do things like send
you this, whether it's in the mail or on our
website.
Or when you call in, have the CSR at the utility
tell you how your heating usage compares to
the average.
This becomes incredibly valuable because we
can start to focus you on where you need to
be-- what actions you need to be taking.
This shows up on our webportal.
We have a breakdown and we bring you to the
first most important part of your usage.
We direct that immediately to recommendations
and we've partnered with retailers and other
third parties to connect this to actions.
Trying to really draw this whole flow through,
we've identified an opportunity, we motivate
you, we explain to you what it is, and then
we say, "Hey look, here's the action that
you can take to insulate your home."
This is where Opower has grown.
We started with this report, and now we have
this whole platform, this customer-centric
experience as we talked to the utilities about
it.
For us consumers, it's just suddenly the utility
actually got smart and is giving you all the
stuff they should be giving you, that makes
energy information easy and digestible.
We have the reports like I showed, we have
a social app that we just launched, we have
this great outage and alerts platform so we
can give you, preemptively, a notification
if you're on track for a high bill before
you get the high bill.
We have all these consumer marketing features
like this coupon I just showed.
We're launching an API platform and mobile
apps, and we have this great website.
Now, also, we're doing in partnership with
Honeywell Thermostat, where we're giving people
the ability to control their usage much more
easily using an Android or iPhone app.
This is what our company has turned into.
But the reason I want to tell you this is
I started with this simple idea.
We identified a blank space and we looked
for making an incremental improvement.
And we did make that improvement, and it steamrolled,
and it snowballed, rather.
You can't do both.
Here's where we are today.
We've saved 900 gigawatt hours, almost a terawatt
hour of energy, which I was just hearing is
about half of what Google uses on an annual
basis.
So in which we all think Google's being a
pretty big power consumer and we're saving
almost half what Google's generating or consuming.
We've saved consumers $100 million, and that
turns into 650,000 tons of CO2.
But all of these reference points, to me,
are not as clear or compelling as this one:
last year, we saved as much energy as half
of the entire US solar industry.
We think of solar as this non-incremental,
transformative, turn-everything-on-its-head
technology.
And it is.
But we, with this incremental approach, have
saved one company half as much energy as all
the solar companies combined did in the US
last year.
If we ran what we do at Opower, it doesn't
have to be Opower, but our approach, worldwide,
it would be 2011 coal-fired power plants that
we could shut down, which is a tremendous,
tremendous amount of energy savings.
This is my point: incrementalism is powerful.
I think that there's so many opportunities
out there.
On Earth Day, the reason why I picked this
as the theme is because when you think about
the-- Earth Day is the day to think globally
and act locally.
Opower is a company that in many ways gets
the pleasure to tally up all of the disparate
thinking globally, acting locally actions
of our customers.
We happen to be able to count it up and report
it out.
But what we're really doing, fundamentally,
is motivating millions of people to make small
changes, and it does make a difference.
So that's my message for today.
Thank you guys for taking the time to come
out.
I'm happy to answer any questions.
[applause]
>>Male #1: [inaudible]Say the question is
about water.
Do we have any opportunity there?
>>Dan Yates: Yeah.
Yeah, we definitely do.
We actually work with, today we work with
both electricity and gas.
We work with a bunch of utilities that serve
both.
We were just talking about this at lunch.
Water is an easy next step for us.
The only reason we've been held back is that
there is just-- While the need is as obvious,
the regulatory and policy infrastructure isn't
there, so the money isn't there.
So it's very hard to find people who will
pay you to do it, and to build a business
on it.
What we have is a number of utilities who
actually provide all three.
Like in Palo Alto, it's gas, electricity,
and water.
I think they even do waste as well.
So we're going to probably start reporting
on water for those utilities.
But it's the same-- and there's another company.
There's a company called waterSMART, I think,
that's trying to do this.
I've heard them calling themselves "The Opower
of water" so I can presume that's what they're
doing.
>>Male #2: So in one of the slides you identified
opportunities for third party app developments
though an API that you'll be offering.
Just curious to hear any ideas you have on
what some of those apps might look like, and
whether or not you think your company will
allow those apps to leverage the energy saving
recommendations that you offer, because I
know that-- I mean, in my mind, there's a
huge market for that.
Just curious to hear what you think some of
these apps might look like.
>>Dan Yates: So we're just getting started
on this.
Actually, Wayne Lin, who is a former Googler,
who is our head of product management for
this part of business, all of our web and
social and API strategy is here today, but
he's not here in the audience.
Otherwise I would just hand it over to him.
There's a couple different things that we're
looking at.
Our order of priority is actually starting
first with the enterprise, and then extending
more and more to third party APIs.
The first set, which we already have live,
is actually, ironically, just giving-- exposing
the analyzed data back to our utility partners
because they don't have the wherewithal to
do this kind of analytics on their own data.
Second evolution for us is building an integration
framework.
For other utility facing companies that want
to provide services to utilities, we can expose
access to that data with utility permission.
Then these providers don't have to integrate
and do all the heavy lifting that we do to
connect with these utilities.
And the third is connecting to third party--
is making it-- putting in place all of the
permission and everything to authenticate
third parties and let consumers turn on and
off different third party apps.
Some of the examples that we have top of mind
are that we got-- Zillow reached out to us.
They're actually very interested in being
able to manifest a certified last 12 months
bill on any new home listings that somebody
can get credit for investing in energy efficiency.
Mint are of a similar interest in being able
to help separate their pie chart of energy
use to show you where your waste is within
your overall consumption, your expenditures.
We've been talking to some weather websites
that are also interested.
So that's been the areas where there's been
the most interest, but one of the APIs that
we've just developed has been top tips.
So exactly to your point, and I think that
there will be a lot of-- that actually is
one of the things the weather companies are
interested in.
"It's going to be hot!
Here's top tips for you for saving energy
this summer."
>>Female #1: How much customization do you
have to do for utilities who want different
levels of engagement?
Have you found that dealing with different
utility personalities has been a tricky part
of the process?
>>Dan Yates: So we are, at the end of the
day, whether I like it or not, an enterprise
software service business.
We deal with big enterprise customers who
write us huge checks and have every right
to ask us to do things for them that, as a
consumer facing company, you would tell that
consumer to go away or buy something else.
The flip side is that enterprise customers
stick with you for a long time.
It's a mutual partnership.
So that sounds like a long way of me saying
we do allow customizations.
We actually don't do a lot of customizations.
We have built-- We do a lot of configuration,
and we've put a lot of configuration into
our platform.
The variants across utilities-- and increasingly
we've been better and better at this as we
continue to invest in our technology.
Utilities vary widely in what they've deployed
in terms of how many reports they've sent
or whether they're system wide or not, but
in terms of the actual features themselves,
we don't build a lot of custom applications
for partners.
I mean, from a business model perspective,
we look in this part of our business at companies
like salesforce dot com or other cloud-based
enterprise companies, where they've built
really thoughtful platforms but then allow
configurability without having to write new
code.
Let the customer write the code.
>>Female #2: It's likely that a lot of people
actually here already understand this.
But you're partnering with a lot of the power
companies.
I'm just not really getting why, what's motivating
them?
>>Dan Yates: Why do utilities do this?
>>Female #2: Yeah, what's the model there?
>>Dan Yates: Mmhmm.
Great question.
[pause] There's a couple different answers.
The way we started the business was very focused
on energy efficiency.
Utilities have state mandates that require
them to hit these efficiency standards that
are called energy efficiency resource standards.
Basically every populous state in the US now
has a standard that these utilities are being
held to.
What happens is the utility commission in
each state will set a goal, a certain terawatt
hour goal or gigawatt hour goal that we've
passed down pro rata to the utilities in that
state.
The utilities will then put together a portfolio
of programs that are proposed back to the
commission every 3 years.
Based upon the costs of those programs, they
will put a tax on the utility bill that funds
these programs.
That's been-- And from a utility perspective
in this regard, it's really compliance exercise.
They don't have any stake in it, but they've
been mandated to do it.
And they definitely adhere to commission mandates
because they commission is their one customer,
really, where they get approval or denial
for building new things.
That was the core value proposition for us
starting the company.
What's happened now is we've grown.
As the utility industry has started to evolve
in this direction, as utilities are realizing
that their future is much more consumer centric
than it ever has been, or certainly for the
last 85 years.
Many of them may be, more than they wish it
were.
But as this political spotlight has been shined
on the utility industry, it's not easy to
go build a dirty coal plant anymore.
So to hit capacity requirements, to handle
new population growth, and to invest in new
infrastructure, which is how utilities make
money, they're finding that all of their new
investments inevitably are more consumer intertwined.
Whether it's smart meters where we've all
heard about the crazy ruckus here about people
being upset about them, or peak reduction
programs where they try to get you to install
a thermostat that reduces your peak usage.
There's a lot of interaction you have to have
with the consumer.
So as utilities are moving in that direction,
they're realizing they need this consumer
infrastructure to engage customers and to
be able to provide a better value.
Also, as rates are rising, which is the other
thing that's happening, is people are not
allowing coal plants to be built.
So for all these reasons, it becomes politically
very important for the utility to have a much
better capability to engage the consumer.
That's how, as we've grown, how this has grown.
It's still the core-- What we like to say
is an energy efficient customer is a happy
customer 'cause we just want to save money
on our bills.
That's a major factor.
So the question is, we have this feedback
loop where we're sending signals once a month.
Do we have the capability to send it faster.
We definitely have the capability to send
it faster.
Then the question is-- We're taking 6 minutes
a year of attention up to 12 minutes.
Can we take it up to 400 minutes?
I think at some point, the answer is no, people
don't actually want to think about their energy
use that much.
So where we're focused-- One of our mantras
for a long time has been insights in analytics
trump real time.
People actually don't want to get feedback
constantly.
They want to get more and more, richer and
richer, more and more tailored feedback.
I always come back to-- I was thinking about
what would my mom want to get?
My mom would love to get a notice in the spring
that says, "Last summer was a doozy.
You paid twice as much as your neighbors on
AC.
Here's the top three things you should do
to save energy this summer on air conditioning."
Rather than getting a weekly or daily email
about her energy use.
That being said, one of the features we've
just rolled out is a weekly smart meter-enabled
update on your usage for people who are engaged
at that level.
We do emails as frequently as people want.
We do alerts now.
We're doing, for some of these utilities that
have load reduction days, we'll send out,
for one utility, 2 million emails in 30 minutes
because we've got to get all of these people
this information.
So I'm hearing two different questions.
Let's see if I can answer this.
[pause] There's this long term challenge of,
okay, so if everybody installs the residential
PV, there's no-- efficiency doesn't matter
anymore.
I've two thoughts, I've number of thoughts
on that.
One is, God, that'd be awesome.
I'd be happy to go out of business if everybody
loaded up with a solar PV.
But on top of that, that's going to be a long,
slow slog.
We've been at it for, it's really in earnest
been going on for 5 years now.
I think that they're just nearing 100,000
solar homes in the US, which is 1/1000 of
the number of homes.
So we've got a long way to go.
Within that, I think there's a ton of opportunity
for us to help promote solar, to help report
back on solar, to aggregate solar on lots
of different things that can be done, and
to be involved in selling it, not just promoting
it.
And financing, etcetera.
That, to me, is a long term opportunity and
problem, and in the same timeframe as solar
starts to happen, that's why we are getting
into the things like thermostats.
And we'll be-- As electric vehicles become
more scaled, we'll be looking at what we can
do there.
The other question was about what if behavior
dries up.
That one is-- I've got at least 100,000 years
of evolutionary history to say that we're
going to stick with the pack for the next
100 years.
That one I'm not too worried about.
[laughs] If you're a City of Palo Alto resident,
you should be getting our home energy reports
which were sent out in the mail or email.
Who is a City of Palo Alto resident here?
>>Male #3: Yeah.
>>Dan Yates: Are you getting it?
What's your neighbor rank?
[laughter] What's your neighbor rank?
Do you know what your neighbor rank is?
>>Male #3: No.
>>Dan Yates: Oh, okay.
I ask 'cause most people tend to know it,
and I always like to highlight it because
the fact that people could remember it is
indicative of the amount of attention it captures.
But unfortunately, this didn't play out so
well with this group.
[laughter]
In Palo Alto, we're just sending out the reports.
We haven't started to do any of the web offerings,
and Palo Alto doesn't have smart meters.
At PG&E, we're sending reports to a lot of
customers, but probably many of you aren't
getting them because we started with them
targeting the largest homes.
We have something like 300,000 homes, I think,
of the 5 million getting reports.
The biggest thing we're doing at PG&E today
is we're powering most of the website.
So when you log into My Energy, the 2 tabs
that are about ways to save and I forget--
the other one was called "my energy use."
Those tabs are entirely powered by us.
And then we also have all of the-- If you
look at changing rates at PG&E, the tool that
helps you analyze that is an Opower tool.
Now I was just talking to Kevin, I don't know
his last name.
>>Male #4: Chen.
>>Dan Yates: Chen, in the sustainability group
about his experience with this rate-switching
tool.
He wanted-- on behalf of him I'll let you
know: when you get to the end, it makes you
call PG&E and then you have to spend half
an hour dealing with their phone tree to finally
get to the point where you can switch your
rates.
That's not our fault.
They were unable to-- They had no APIs to
send rate switch signals to any piece of their
infrastructure, so we have to, basically,
put a little thing that says, "Call PG&E and
read them this."
Implementations are imperfect with these utilities,
but it's been exciting what we're-- PG&E's
actually been a great customer.
They also have signed onto the social apps.
So if you go to social dot opower dot com,
you can utility connect with both PG&E and
City of Palo Alto and you can compare with
your friends.
We're continuing to invest a lot in that application.
We just launched it and there's a lot more
to do.
>> Female #3:
>>Dan Yates: Yeah, so we-- The question is:
how have we tackled commercial building?
There's 2 areas in commercial building that
we're probably not going to tackle.
One is where there's a master meter building,
where there isn't individually metering because
we just don't have-- we're all about the meter
data, and at least now, we're not in the business
of metering.
So we wait for people to do their own metering.
And a lot of places in older buildings that
are not individually metered, it's not just--
the electric circuits actually don't enable
individual metering, so it's not trivial.
The other place is really big buildings and
big commercial enterprises.
We're probably not-- It's going to be a long
time before we get there.
And the reason there is that it's just a different
problem set.
If you can afford-- If you have a full-time
energy manager like Walmart does, and they
have a whole team of them, and you can afford
to have people come on site and do audits,
our expertise in behavioral psychology and
direct marketing is out-gunned by door knockers.
Where we are expanding is into small, medium
businesses which in many ways is like a stratified
prosumer or heavy, large consumer.
There we are, we've already done some stuff
and we're looking to do more.
>>Male #5: I've a question about the size
of the opportunity ahead of you.
You made a comparison to the solar industry,
so obviously you're doing huge work in energy
reduction.
But solar's really low on its exponential
curve.
You cited some numbers for how many installations
there are residentially.
But you-- So I heard a couple numbers from
you, which is that you have half of all US
energy usage under management.
If that's the case, and you're asymptotically
approaching 2-3%--
>>Then I can only double and then I'm done.
Yeah, let me answer that.
Yeah.
So we have-- That's great.
This is a very smart audience.
All of my little stats are being finally picked
apart in the right way, which is good.
So we manage half of the US energy data right
now on behalf of these utilities, which is
a great capability.
It's a great position to be in so that we
can do things like launch an API platform
or launch APIs on our platform, or we can--
For example, with social, when we turned it
on for a new utility, we didn't have to get
any more data from them.
We already had it.
But we are only monetizing probably 10% of
that data that we have under management.
So a good example is when we sold Com Edison
in the Illinois region and Chicago land area.
We had a 50,000 home program with them, and
they gave us all 3 million homes worth of
data.
That's the case all over the place.
To talk about our business, our TAM is in
the multiple billions of dollars, between
3 and 5 billion.
We're nowhere near that right now in terms
of our growth.
As we serve-- There's a lot of great stuff
ahead of us.
so our big expansion areas are domestically
in the US we still have new utilities to sell,
and we have a lot of expansion with our existing
utilities.
And then we're just now starting to really
expand internationally.
That opportunity is as big as the US opportunity.
And that's just market expansion.
Then we continue to build new products, like
this thermostat which I'm excited about.
It's going to be a total new product line.
It's actually interesting.
We haven't actually looked that much at the
interfaces much on cars . We did-- I was at
an event last spring, and I actually talked
to a business development guy from GM who
said, "Hey, you should come talk to us, 'cause
we're designing some new cars and we want
to talk to you about the interface."
And we just didn't make it high enough up
on the priority list.
We didn't feel like it was believable.
It's going to be small scale, and they don't
have an electric car yet, or they almost do
but not quite.
So that is an interesting opportunity.
I think we haven't looked into that that much.
The area where we've thought a little bit
more is charging management, because that's
where the utilities-- The utilities are thrilled
that there's going to be these new power consumers
on their grid using up more energy, and they
can make money off of them.
But what they're confused about is: how's
this going to work?
Because an electric vehicle in charging mode
is like a house, so it's like you're driving
houses around and jamming them into the grid.
All of a sudden, the transformer melts.
That's very, very expensive compared to the
value of the electricity from the car.
So they're trying to get a handle on how they
manage that.
There are lots of companies that are astutely
going after this in a way that we haven't
yet, but it's an area that we're monitoring.
>> Male #6: Inaudible
>>Yeah, so there's a lot of different-- people
taking a lot of different tacks.
One is the charging station that works like
Zipcar for charging.
Well, not really, but whatever.
You get it.
And another way is, Better Place has tried
to do it, where you have replaceable batteries
and there's essentially gas stations for batteries.
And then there's the third way, which is that
people just don't have either and you just
charge your car at home and maybe cut a deal
at your office to charge your car there.
I think it's to be seen how much these other--
I think this is all early days.
It's to be seen what's going to stick or not.
>>Male #7: Is it that bad?
>>No, I think it's actually not that complicated.
There are a lot of decoy facts out there that
are hard to parse out, like the tiered pricing,
which is a mandated structure from-- This
is a California phenomenon.
It's manned by the utility commission as a
way to try to, essentially, charge rich people
more for electricity and discourage overconsumption.
But that's not a fact of the energy market.
It's a policy manipulation.
The core dynamic is-- Just think about cell
phone companies.
They have a network they put a lot of money
into.
They want you to use it.
But they max out at peak times, and then they
have these trough times where there's no usage.
Just like cell phone networks, they have all
these-- they can't shut down the base stations
at night.
Even if they did, it doesn't matter because
the base station is you build as many of them
out to meet peak demand, not because of--
and so it's just wasted at night.
The cell phone companies would be happy to
pay you, probably, to use their network.
It means nothing to them at night time.
It's why they have nights and weekend plans.
So it's the exact same thing with utilities
and with the peak usage and the off-time usage.
And with coal plants, the problem is, and
with all these baseload plants, is they literally
take 24 hours to power up, so they can't shut
them off at night.
So that is not just a waste of capital in
the infrastructure, but it's actually a huge
waste of emissions and fuel.
So the utilities are motivated to reduce peak.
They have an endemic interest in doing that.
Then the commissions, which are-- you should
think of them as your proxy-- are motivated
in reducing overall usage because they want
to save people money and help the environment.
So the commissions will set these efficiency
standards, and the utilities go out and try
to come up with ways to shave peak.
Those are basically the two major dynamics.
In the top hours, it's a loss.
In the worst hours of the year, it can be
a loss, depending on the utility.
If the utility has their own generation or
they're buying on the open market.
Yeah.
When the utility exec wakes up in the morning,
he does not want, or she does not want, to
deliver energy efficiency.
They may be interested.
They are in many cases interested in reducing
peak.
And then the commission wakes up in the morning
and says, "I want to save citizens of California
energy and money and help the environment."
And that's the group who says, "Let's have
an efficiency standard."
And then the utility says, "Well, if they
want it, I got to endear myself to them because
they're my buyer, when I go to try to sell
this next thing.
So maybe I should take into consideration
this efficiency stuff."
And then the complex political intertanglings
continue to unfold.
But those are the two major fundamentals.
All right.
Thank you guys so much for so many great questions.
[applause]